carnot benedetti rédacteur en chef de la
revue politique et parlementaire
bonjour à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce matin alors
maintenant que nous sommes aux portes du
pic de l'épidémie en france beaucoup de
questions dont celle ci qui revient fall
est il oui ou non maintenir le premier
tour de ces municipales il ya dix jours
on s'en souvient dans les colonnes du
monde
l'ex ministre de la santé agnès buzyn
avait déclaré qu'elle avait déconseillé
justement la tenue du premier tour des
élections municipales elle avait
déconseillé au premier ministre est ce
que cette affaire finalement ça risque
de devenir un boomerang juste le point
qu'avec sur les déclarations de madame
busin il était surprenant qu'elle est
déconseillé au pénis très qu'elle soit
candidate et trois semaines plus tard
donc il n'y a qu'à une chambre d'à
cohérence pour son comportement passé
mais ceci dit sur le fond c'est que la
réalité c'est que au moment où la
question s'est posée c'est à dire trois
ou quatre jours c'est à dire le jeudi
avant le premier tour le niveau
d'information notamment de l'ensemble
des forces politiques n'étaient pas
suffisants pour que se dégage un
consensus national afin que ce retour
soit opéré il eût fallu
vraisemblablement en l'occurrence que
l'exécutif prenne cette question bien en
amont c'est à dire quinze jours avant la
tenue du premier tour
on a reçu à matignon à ce moment là
l'ensemble des responsables politiques
des responsables de groupes
parlementaires pour les informer sur la
situation sanitaire du pays sur les
mesures quand on dépend droite le
gouvernement en la matière la question
des municipal n'a jamais été évoqué donc
c'est vrai savoir le défaut de
réactivité qui a manqué dans cette
affaire aujourd'hui quand même
clairement très explicitement les faits
démontrent qui lui valut en effet
reporté ce premier tour des élections
municipales alors défaut de réactivité
une question encore concerne le
confinement est ce qu'on peut être qu'on
aurait pu décider ce confinement total
bien avant l'arrivée de l'épidémie ou
pas anticipé puisque on avait de
l'avancé difficile c'est en effet on
avait quand même la situation italienne
aux portes
de chez nous qui montrait que nous
étions face à une épidémie
particulièrement virulente
l'arrêté c'est que il ya deux sujets il
ya le premier sujet de la formation
scientifique et de la formation
sanitaire l'information scientifique
n'étant pas stabilisée il est
extrêmement difficile en effet pour les
autorités sanitaires c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire de pouvoir prendre les
bonnes décisions non pas que les
scientifiques soient responsables c'est
être fait mais ils sont en train de
chercher et d'essayer de comprendre des
caractéristiques du virus
l'autre l'autre l'autre sujet c'est que
finalement ce n'est pas temps
aujourd'hui la question du confinement
en temps et en heure qui pose problème
c'est plus finalement la question de la
du manque d'un certain nombre de moyens
qui auraient peut-être pu permettre
qu'on combiné avec le confinement de
limiter la propagation de l'épidémie
c'est la question des marques ce que
c'est la question des tests entre autres
et on on ne souhaite pas mais
possiblement aussi la question des
appareils respiratoires on est dans les
hôpitaux et dans les urgences dont
quelques dans quelques jours qui pose
véritablement problème il ya un
collectif de médecins ces 19 t a annoncé
son intention de poursuivre l'ancien
ministre de la santé agnès buzyn on en
parle est l'actuel premier ministre
devant la cour de justice pour mensonge
d'état une pétition sur internet avec
plus de deux cent mille signatures
dénonce l'amateurisme du gouvernement
ça veut dire que l'étau finalement il
commence à se resserrer autour de ce
gouvernement
à côté il ya deux temps il ya le temps
de l'urgence qui consiste en effet à
mobiliser l'ensemble de la nation pour
lutter conte battre avec les moyens qui
sont les nôtres l'épidémie il y aura un
volet 120 est devenu le temps de
l'évaluation de la façon dont cette
crise a été gérée ce depuis le début
janvier
on parle de commission d'enquêté
parlementaire qui se mettrait en place
trotz et l'a déjà laissé entendre qu'une
commission d' enquête viendrait le
moment venu lécher essayer de comprendre
les raisons pour lesquelles un certain
nombre de dysfonctionnements sont à
l'origine aussi delà de la crise
laquelle
nous retrouvons ce l'épisode judiciaire
c'est haine de l'autre cet anneau temps
il est encore trop tôt au jour où j'ai
signé des chances d'aboutir ce qui est
sûr c'est que quand mamie il existe
quelle dans la constitution un principe
qui est un principe simple qui est le
principe de précaution est ce que
finalement l'ensemble des mesures qui
ont été pris depuis le début de cette
crise ont permis de décliner ce principe
de précaution qui est un classique pour
steven faut-il faut-il le rappeler
ça c'est évidemment une question qui ne
manquera pas de se poser
le moment donné alors c'est vrai que
beaucoup de médecins en tout cas ce
collectif réclame aussi beaucoup de
transparence edouard philippe doit
s'exprimer
cet après midi l'enjeu en matière de
communication pour le gouvernement
l'exécutif cadets cet enjeu aujourd'hui
il est de ramasser sa communication pour
éviter que de nouveaux messages soient
contradictoires soit maladroit viennent
d'horizons une unité nationale qui est
extrêmement fragile et on a vu que par
rapport à un certain nombre de
maladresses commises par certains
ministres par rapport à un certain
nombre de messages parfois paradoxaux
qui ont été envoyés à la population il
est nécessaire que celui qui conduit la
politique de la nation sur l'article 20
de la constitution c'est-à-dire le
premier ministre vienne aujourd'hui
leach il le fait d'ailleurs maintenant
de manière un peu plus régulière
s'exprimer devant les français pour tout
simplement donner plus de cohérence à
cette communication et surtout plus de
transparence je crois que finalement il
ya peut-être deux erreurs qui ont été
commises dans la communication de
l'exécutif depuis le début de cette
crise c'est une forme d' absence de
discours de vérité et une absence
finalement d' excuses par rapport à un
certain nombre de dysfonctionnements qui
ont pu finalement gêner la bonne gestion
de cette crise
la difficulté c'est que quand vous
faites de la communication en temps de
crise ne pouvait pas faire de la
propagande
la propagande en temps de guerre c'est
ce qu'on faisait en 14 18 mai il y avait
de la tension et la censure était
finalement la condition pour que la
propagande fonctions parce qu'on
appelait le bourrage de crâne
aujourd'hui dans une société
démocratique dans une société de
l'information dans une société de
réseaux
il est clair que l'information circule
normal c'est un droit démocratique il
faut s'en féliciter tous les jours et il
est naturel en l'occurrence toute chose
il est absolument essentiel pardon que
la communication de l'exécutif soit une
communication de greek et et
reconnaissent il ya des manques de
moyens et le dise aux françaises et aux
français
merci beaucoup arnaud benedetti en
direct sur arte france ce matin je
rappelle que vous êtes rédacteur en chef
de la revue politique et parlementaire
merci